It's one of the most visited places on earth,...
...but hidden from the eyes of tourists,...
...these people wait in line behind the Vatican's Bernini Columns.
They're homeless.
They're hoping to take a shower and get a haircut in the newly opened shower stalls.
This really helps us out a lot.
It's great for people like us who don't have a house or any belongings.
It's a very difficult situation to be in.
This Vatican Barbershop is proof that there are people willing to help.
Once a week, Marco takes a four-hour train ride from his neighborhood to Rome,...
...to donate his services.
They've taught me to never make a distinction between those who have money and those who don't.
They've shown me to look at people with integrity because everyone deserves to be listened to.
He's been a hairdresser for the last 40 years.
It's what he does for a living.
But coming to Rome to help the homeless isn't about money or profit.
Helping the needy, he says, is something that money just can't buy.